[Musique]
l'accueil est individualisé au musée du
jouet de poissy pas question de se
retrouver dans une file épidémie oblige
l'accès est réglementé
les visiteurs doivent réserver au
préalable et venir masquer il ya des
choses plus particulière à l'intérieur
des salles qu'on a dû aménager puisque
quand le musée a réouvert l'année
dernière après des longs travaux on a
beaucoup développé tout ce qui était
tactile là c'est tout ce qu'il ne faut
pas faire donc on a enlevé les espaces
vieux malheureusement dans ce serait une
dit un petit peu moins ludique mais on
se concentrera plus sur les collections
une famille par pièce des infections à
chaque passage considéré comme petit
musée le site pisciacais a rouvert ses
portes mercredi 13 mai une opportunité
saisie par cette famille yvelinoise
après deux mois de confinement
cette sortie était attendue j'aime bien
les jouer et j'aime tout seul son petit
quartier c'est une première sortie pour
nos depuis donc le confinement
même si on attend tout de même de trois
jours
ça nous a permis de souffler un peu puis
c'est mercredi du coup les enfants enfin
les filles n'ont pas de devoirs ça nous
a permis un petit peu de souffle et
devant un petit peu autre chose
les capacités d'accueil ont été réduites
de moitié les équipes ont dû annuler les
médiations culturelles au moins jusqu'à
la fin du mois de juin le musée du jouet
reçoit 18 mille visiteurs par an